As one of the Teen Titans' most memorable
enemies, Trigon has shown up to menace nearly
every incarnation of the team, but what is
it that makes this demon so memorable?
Join us as we dive into the forbidden history
of Raven's fearsome father and all the havoc
he has wreaked.
Trigon, unstoppable avatar of evil and bringer
of doom, began his immortal life as a mistake
on the part of the good guys.
Centuries ago, a band of humans who were weary
of human suffering created a haven between
dimensions, the place that would become Azarath.
It was paradise built by human hands.
Led by Azar, a visionary mystic, the pacifists
of Azarath decided to cement their utopia
by purging it of all evil.
At first, they seemed to have succeeded in
this monumental task, but the dark energy
began to coalesce into something altogether
darker.
Ages passed, until a sect on a doomed and
distant planet summoned a dark spirit in a
last-ditch attempt at survival.
The cast-off energy inhabited a woman of the
order, and nine months later, Trigon was born.
His first act was to slaughter his mother
and her compatriots, which was the beginning
of a long and bloody career of conquest.
Like many comic characters, Trigon doesn't
have one singular origin.
The "New 52," a line-wide reboot of the DC
universe's characters and continuity, gave
Trigon an alternate origin rooted in even
more potent forms of evil.
According to Teen Titans #23.1, a "Villain
Month" special where the bad guys stepped
into the spotlight, Trigon was created through
the folly of a trio of alien beings known
as the Divine.
Acting as interstellar peacekeepers, they
discovered a world they'd thought was cleansed
of wickedness had devolved into brutal chaos.
After finding the man responsible, the Divine
attempted to quarantine him by feeding him
to the Heart of Darkness, an inescapable abyss
to which they consigned all evil.
But the culprit was a juvenile Trigon, and
his power was too great.
Instead of being consumed by the Heart, he
consumed it, thus devouring the millions of
wicked souls the Divine had placed within
it.
Flooded with power, Trigon killed the Divine
and resolved to blanket the universe in his evil.
But he quickly found that he couldn't escape
a barrier the Divine had erected.
Undaunted, he began to transport female humanoids
his way, to be impregnated and spread his
unholy soul throughout the cosmos.
While Raven's mother, Arella,
had originally been fooled by a mystical disguise,
she eventually learned the truth of her daughter's
parentage: the demon Trigon was Raven's father.
Though some on Azarath wary of Raven, given
her demonic ancestry, she was allowed to grow,
learn, and master her powers within the sanctity
of its borders.
But not even an interdimensional Eden could
shelter Raven for long, nor keep her ignorant
of her father's thirst for power.
Terrified of what he might unleash upon an
unsuspecting populace, Raven traveled to Earth
and asked the Justice League for aid.
When she was turned away, she had no choice
but to gather a team of heroes on her own:
the lineup that would become the New Teen
Titans.
In this way, Trigon planted the seed of his
own destruction.
Fear of him didn't keep Raven quiet, pliable,
or cowed it empowered her to defy him, regardless
of the consequences.
She refused to further her father's destructive
agenda, refused to accept the Justice League's
cold shoulder, and finally, refused to give
in to the Armageddon that Trigon briefly brought
to the Earth.
Trigon might've thought fathering half-demon
children would seal his eventual victory,
but he didn't count on their human halves
winning out.
Raven gained her powers through her demonic
parentage, but it was her ability to love,
find fellowship, and work alongside her friends
that truly mattered in the fight against her father.
With Trigon's level of hellish power to deal
with, it makes sense to ask how the Teen Titans
finally managed to bring down the terror of
a thousand worlds.
Well, it wasn't easy.
An initial attempt that combined all of the
Titans' powers, Arella's empathic abilities,
and an interdimensional portal, put him away
for a while, but it didn't destroy him entirely.
Trigon, ever patient, bided his time, ruminating
upon the abilities of Raven's new team and
how he might counter them, steadily growing
in power until he was able to break free of his bonds.
In one terrifying campaign of violence, Trigon
laid siege to Azarath, murdered its inhabitants,
and corrupted Raven's soul entirely.
But the souls of Azarath hadn't dissolved
into the ether.
Being magically powerful, they dwelt within
the Rings of Azar, holy relics worn by Raven.
In a complex plan, the Titans were taken over
by Trigon's evil and murdered Raven, a terrible
act that nevertheless allowed the souls of
Azarath to use her as a channel.
Trigon was then blasted with pure Azarathian
light, and his soul was disincorporated and
his body torn apart.
With Trigon seemingly vanquished, Raven came
back to life, and the world returned to normal.
Good had won … but not without a battle
few of the Titans would ever be able to forget.
Raven is, of course, Trigon's most famous
child.
But the legendary baddie made sure to have
far more than one kid to choose from when
it came to his nefarious plans.
Hundreds of Trigon's offspring populate the
DC universe, many of them possibly even ignorant
of their heritage.
Raven wasn't so lucky, and neither were the
boys who became known as the Sons of Trigon.
Introduced in 2008's Titans #3, there were
originally six members of the group called
the Sons of Trigon.
Conceived around the same time Raven was,
they were intended to embody the seven deadly
sins, with Raven as the seventh, representing
pride.
Jesse, Jared, and Jacob (envy, wrath, and
lust, respectively) emerged as the leaders
of the heinous septet, and they used Raven
as a portal to where their weakened father
slumbered.
And yet, they didn't raise him, as you might
expect.
Instead, they stole away his power for themselves,
an act so evil that it actually made their
fearsome father smile.
They were, of course, eventually defeated
by Raven and the Titans, but the idea of Raven
having siblings was an intriguing enough notion
that after the New 52 reboot, it was reintroduced
in 2013 in the pages of The Phantom Stranger
#2.
Nowadays, Raven has three brothers named Belial,
Ruskoff, and Suge.
What havoc they might wreak remains to be
seen, but it's a pretty safe bt for readers
to assume it will be terrible when it arrives.
Initially, the New 52 meant a fresh start
for Raven as a typical girl named Rachel Roth.
But Trigon's daughter never gets a reprieve
for long, and the Phantom Stranger ultimately
delivered her back into the arms of her father.
After a stretch of time in the "under-realms,"
Raven reemerged as her father's "black bird
of terror," keen to conquer the world on his
behalf.
Trigon had, in fact, discovered a certain
respect for his daughter over the course of
their time together, naming her as his favorite
child and seeking to use her as a spearhead
for future attacks on Earth.
Naturally, Raven turned against him, saved
the world alongside the Titans, and sent Trigon
back to where he came from.
She hadn't ever truly been his creature.
Instead, she'd merely become an impeccable
actress.
Even with that, though, Trigon's favoritism
was striking during this period, and he even
desired to install Raven upon the throne.
As Trigon detailed while torturing his other
three children, Raven's knowledge of love,
compassion, and justice would, he believed,
make her a conqueror he himself couldn't become.
It's a twisted sort of respect, to be certain,
and still largely self-serving.
But for a time, Trigon saw his daughter as
greater than himself, if only in one crucial aspect.
Trigon is an all-star villain, the sort of
world-shattering powerhouse whose appearances
require entire storylines' worth of buildup,
execution, and resolution.
His is an evil that extends beyond his own
stories, however, to the point of creating
entirely separate bad guys.
Psimon, an enormously powerful psychic, is
the most famous example of Trigon's proteges.
Once a physicist seeking to blaze new trails
in dimensional exploration, he got quite a
bit more than he bargained for when he accidentally
breached Trigon's realm.
Seizing this rare opportunity, Trigon imbued
the hapless scientist with devastating mental
abilities, twisted him towards his own desire
to conquer the Earth, and, presumably, told
him to start spelling his name with a silent
P. Psimon set out to further Trigon's mission,
joined the Fearsome Five, and began a long
and ugly career of brutality, manipulation,
and violence.
However, he didn't actually end up doing much
to carry out Trigon's plans, and after a stint
of banishment, he appeared to have been forgotten
by his dark master.
Unfortunately, that didn't stop Psimon from
using his powers for evil, and if anything,
he'd been freed to create as much panic and
mayhem as he liked, following no agenda but
his own desire to inflict cruelty.
Psimon stands as a monument to Trigon's malice
and power, a decent member of society left
shattered and rotten by a passing glance from
worlds-shaking evil.
What Trigon started, though, the Joker ended.
When most of DC's villains were trapped on
another planet, Psimon annoyed the Clown Prince
of Crime so much that he wound up finding
out why it's a bad idea to keep your brain
inside a glass dome.
One of the best things about superhero comics
is their multiple-choice approach to storytelling.
So it goes with Trigon.
Perhaps his most unique form is that of "Das
Trigon," a villain of the DC Bombshells series.
Within the Bombshells universe, Trigon was
a German mountain spirit whose liaison with
a human woman led to Raven.
Here, Raven grew up in a small Alpine village,
instructed by her grandfather in the control
of her powers until the Joker's daughter upended
her tranquil life.
Eventually, Raven rediscovered her father
working for dark masters, but this wasn't
the aimless evil of Trigon's past.
In this story, Trigon felt utterly untethered
when Raven's mother died, so he gave up on
goodness to join the dastardly General Faora
… until Faora threatened Raven's life.
Trigon fell defending his daughter, who buried
him beneath a tree and wept for the father
she'd never known as well as she would've
liked.
It was a very different Trigon, indeed, and
all the more affecting for it.
These days, most kids know the Teen Titans
from Teen Titans Go!, where Robin, Starfire,
Beast Boy, Raven, and Cyborg spend more time
scarfing burritos and getting into wacky scrapes
involving waffles than they do crime-fighting.
For as off-the-wall as the cartoon is, however,
it digs deeply into DC's vast and complex
history including, of course, Trigon and all
the terror he's visited upon the Titans.
But like so many classic characters who've
made an appearance on Teen Titans Go!, this
cartoon version of Trigon is … rather different.
Instead of his usual look — you know, capes,
ragged loincloths, giant demonic antlers — he
wears sweater vests, slacks, and neckties.
And sure, yes, he's described as the "master
of the dark, destroyer of dimensions, enslaver
of civilizations," but, well, he does make
sure to always spend Thanksgiving with his
daughter.
And when Demon Prom rolls around, he nominates
Raven for Prom Queen.
And he does spend Father's Day leafing through
treasured photos of his baby girl.
Trigon is a bad guy in Teen Titans Go!, but
that doesn't necessarily mean he's a bad dad.
He might want to rule the Earth, but he also
wants what's best for his precious daughter,
no matter how embarrassed that might make
her.
"I'm so proud. The only thing left to do is kill your friends."
"Kill us kill us!
You can totally do it!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.